Ma quanto è brutto questo pupazzo
cattivo non sta facendo cadere i
meteoriti dal cielo Uh Benvenuti Serie A
Stories dobbiamo scappare dal papà
cattivo come sempre poi alla fine del
video scriveteci un voto da 1 a 10 per
questa nuova Escape Room la scatola che
mi piace vedete i comodi prendete i
Popcorn qualcosa da mangiare Ciao bello
da mangiare ci siamo
subito che è pronto via gioca Ecco qua
ovviamente dice facile o difficile
difficile
a voi piace tantissimo la prima persona
nei giochi cioè che si vede proprio in
prima persona e non si vede il
personaggio da fuori in terza persona
quindi proviamolo in prima persona e via
Eccoci qua Ma dove siamo Ma è un posto
un po' strano che cosa dice tappeto
Arcobaleno bobina di velocità capacità
di velocità
che c'è
il papà cattivo ci ha intrappolato devi
scappare attraverso queste Fessure Ok
andiamo Ehi aspetta Ma io voglio
esplorare un po' La Staffa hai capito
questo papà cattivo è molto cattivo
Guarda che cosa ha fatto questa poltrona
Oh no l'ha accettata non è che l'ha
accettata così
Qui c'è un pezzo di lego rotto gigante
Qua c'è qualcuno
e c'è una freccia ma
con questo forse era qualcuno che ha
fatto a fette Può essere sì e poi che
stanza strana Ah no c'è anche altri
presidenti americani Qui c'è un'altra
accetta e questo c'è la foto di una
persona con le orecchie da unicorno e le
ali blu e poi c'è anche un crewmate
Guarda c'è rosso
diamongas
meglio andarsene da questo posto strano
scambiamo Oh ma non mi hai rispettato
sei andata avanti Ciao ciao un posto di
blocco o no questa è la macchina del
papà cattivo è tipo una specie di camion
è gigante sembra un cambio
hai visto il negozio di Avatar qui puoi
cambiare l'outfit Sì ma chissà quanti
robux chiedono Quindi io vado avanti
Ciao ciao
No mi sono sfracellata che figo ma c'è
un furgone Sì ma non si può entrare
dentro purtroppo cosa avremmo potuto
prendere Ma come hai fatto a
sfracellarmi di nuovo perché sei
inciampata nella chiave inglese
No vabbè ma io salto mi sfracello perché
riproviamo devi saltare queste chiavi
inglesi che stanno per terra vedi brava
no Hai visto Mi sono sfracellata lo
stesso Guarda vedi che io ci riesco vado
avanti e indietro Oh sei riuscita perché
è più facile in terza persona in prima
persona è più difficile attento il
pavimento tossico
tanto ti supera anche se sono in prima
persona ti sei ancora lo stesso Ciao
ci saranno Ehi non capisco niente Guarda
ho trovato qui il passaggio segreto
vieni non è un passaggio segreto
finalmente abbiamo visto Vitale
sfracellato da uno di questi coltelli
Ma io stavo saltando sulle parti bianche
È bellissimo
Comunque io mi sono sfracellata su un
cucchiaio
vediamo cosa ci dice il Natale Il papà
cattivo è sta arrivando dobbiamo è sulla
strada dobbiamo tenere la chiave per
aprire la porta e scappare
Ah eccolo qui lo vedi è bruttissimo
Aiuto Mi stai seguendo mi stai seguendo
mi stai seguendo aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto ma
quanto è brutto questo Puffo è cattivo
Ah ah ah
ah aspetta me la sognerò stanotte
Avete visto che faccia brutta che ha ti
volevo dire Guarda ti puoi nascondere
sotto il tavolo non riuscirà a prenderti
Ok ma questo tavolo è chiuso no sotto le
sedie qui vai Vieni vieni io sono qui
camminata Ciao Ale fammi sapere una cosa
perché è tutto gigante e noi siamo
piccolissimi come se noi fossimo delle
formiche questo è giusto Non te lo so
spiegare Allora proviamo a vedere dove
possiamo scappare
di fronte tranne le gambe le gambe sono
piccolissime
proviamo un'altra strada vediamo dove
possiamo andare
Allora lui ci sta inseguendo di qua mi
nascondo qua sotto al tavolo Bravo bravo
andiamo verso la porta di uscita senza
guardarsi indietro perché non si apre
questa porta maledetta no sei stato
preso tipo
[Musica]
Aiuto sto arrivando No non si apre ci
deve essere un altro passaggio
che nell'altra freccia qui vicino alla
lavastoviglie Ah giusto dobbiamo
prendere la chiave dobbiamo salire qua
sopra prendi la chiave presa due Eccolo
qua il lavandino della cucina del
lavandino e poi verso la porta e ti ho
visto buttarti giù dal lavandino ce l'ho
fatta dai Anita Corri corri il papà è
distratto dai ti aspetto qui
obiettivo aiuto aiuto aiuto
Brava brava
i laser Li odio sono quelli che odio di
più attenta Attenta gli angoli che tu di
solito negli angoli inciampi
Ok Attenta qui nascosti in mezzo alle
scale questi sono difficili
Sì sono in testa
Sì è caduta sulle scale ci sono i
quadretti di famiglia ma cosa c'entra
Ariana Grande C'è qualcosa di strano
Questa casa qua c'è un ritratto del papà
cattivo ma è bruttissima e infatti ho
paura che mi sono sfracellata Ma allora
dove devo andare qua senza No aspetta ce
l'ho fatta a passare lo stesso Forse per
andare
Uffa Non ho capito dove devo passare
io passano il quadro mi sfracello
Ma tu sei in terza persona No non mi
dire che io mi sono buggato Ah ho capito
devo fare Sono salta salta Ciao ciao
Matteo Ciao posto di blocco
trova la chiave e apri la porta dobbiamo
trovare la chiave siamo nella camera da
letto dove sarà la chiave Forse sotto al
letto Qua c'è un cassetto dove nel
cassetto sotto al letto Eccola l'ho
trovata
io c'erano freccia gigante che Ok chiamo
impresa e adesso voglio vedere cosa c'è
in questo in questo quadretto ma non
riesco a salire Va bene non fa niente
Cioè tutti i giocatori siamo anche noi
no
sono quelli che sono riusciti a scappare
dal papà cattivo dove dobbiamo andare
adesso con questa chiave Ehi dove
dobbiamo andare Uffa Non si capisce
Dietro lo specchio indietro Dietro lo
specchio No non c'è niente dentro l'ho
spento la TV
dietro dietro l'armadio ma qui c'è
un'altra volta
così semplice
Mamma mia
Oh guarda che ci sono io me ne accorgo
altri quadri
dietro dietro
aiuto
sicuramente ci vuole mangiare quella
pizza per prendere aiuto
è brutto riproviamo questa volta non mi
devo girare non devo guardare indietro
non devo guardare indietro Altrimenti mi
prende Eh la verità scappa scappa scappa
di aprirlo Brava Evviva Allora i miei
preferiti
Vitale che credi di essere sempre più
bravo si è sfracellato
Guarda come sono caduto
Ehi ma come faccio Non sfracellarmi qui
mi sto facendo sempre Mi dispiace ma io
sono in testa Adesso andiamo per quanto
tempo ancora e dove
siete ti vedo vediamo no questa era la
strada sbagliata
c'era un piccolo genio Quindi se mi dici
che quella ho trovato la strada giusta
dai
Vieni vieni Brava vieni vieni Salviamo e
indovina chi è in vantaggio
Oh che dobbiamo fare qui premiamo
Stai attento il pavimento è lavato No
non ci spendiamo non devi cadere devi
cadere giù nel pavimento
stiamo attenti al nostro cellulare Certo
che è molto strana questa casa del papà
cattivo cioè soprattutto il pavimento
lava dentro casa non stavo tornando
indietro ho sbagliato devo andare Qua mi
sono bloccato vediamo dov'è È lì Ciao
Anita Ciao ciao Ma ancora per poco Dai
che ti aspetto qui al posto di blocco
Chi è blocco il posto di blocco
pensavo al posto di blocco una persona
no sbloccata altri laser prima o poi
cadrà Vitale e io tornerò in testa come
sempre che cosa fa questo bottone
ma non è successo niente No devo tornare
indietro
fai prima no aspetta
dobbiamo stare qua Sì devo premere
quest'altro pulsante lo vedete chi ha
votato Chievo
ho aperto il nuovo passaggio e ora
prenderò invece no
prima io il papà cattivo Allora questi
laser rotanti sono super difficili per
me Ehi Dominick
[Applauso]
perchè non mi fa scivolare ma siamo
finiti nelle prigioni chi c'è qui siamo
di nuovo in prigione No non eravamo in
prigione prima non lo so Mi stavo
confondendo con un'altra Escape Room che
in genere siamo in prigione
però lui ha chiuso in prigione le altre
persone quindi se ci facciamo prendere
agli altri giocatori dici devi risolvere
i puzzle Insomma agli enigmi e gli
indovinelli in ogni tanto scappare e
premere i bottoni per scappare Io adoro
gli indovinelli ok Un po' proprio forse
qua si salva puzzle ma qui non si deve
cadere attenzione
Luna come non detto
ma aspetta eh Allora qui ci abbiamo i
laser Verdi i Preferiti di Anita Tra
l'altro no
tanto faccio prima io perché ho premuto
il pulsante oro ho aperto un'altra porta
che non so dove sia abbiamo sbloccato
abbiamo sbloccato una porta qui credo
che dobbiamo tornare indietro però
salta qui sull'angolo brava
Ok andiamo me la ricordo Allora
c'abbiamo
quella parte più piccola più sottile Ah
è vero Ecco perché mi sono sfracellata
ormai siamo esperti Parkour Allora
qui qui qui qui qui c'è il pulsante
premuto aiuto abbiamo sbloccato un'altra
porta perfetto
sta cadendo il tempo
fruttati io sono più bravo fra poco
scadente Non riusciremo ad attraversarla
il tempo scaduto cosa succede
che cosa sta succedendo in vita
No io sono ancora vivo meglio non
premere niente Oppure possiamo fare una
bomba al papà cattivo Forse vuole dire
questo non lo so ma c'abbiamo la super
velocità Ah allora ma dobbiamo stare
sopra attenti adesso uhm uhm
[Musica]
C'è mancato poco
Esatto doppio senso
Ok salvato Dove sei Anita Ah la super
velocità però è facilissimo
che c'è sono sulla giornata alla fine ma
per fortuna che avevo salvato
Anch'io voglio salvare Ok Ora possiamo
continuare la nostra super gara di
velocità
Avevi buttato giù adesso
Io adoro la super velocità
[Musica]
Mi manca solo un salto siamo riusciti a
scappare già No ma come all'ultimo
minuto
tutta la corsa devi sfruttare lasciate
un mi piace per portarmi fortuna Vai
Brava Anita ne mancano tre due uno
Brava brava
Non è come sempre dobbiamo prendere
quelle armi e sconfiggere il papà
cattivo Oh no ok
sconfiggiamo è gigante così figo è un
coso laser è un farmaco una pistola la
lavatrice
le cose oh oh oh Ehi se tieni premuto
spara di più guarda guarda
È vero
Ah mi ha preso facciamo 400 questa volta
non ce la farai Dai dai Manca poco
adesso riusciamo
a sconfiggere Che cosa succede se premo
testata nucleare l'ho premuto Ah no no è
a pagamento
no vi ho preso di nuovo Anita aiuto
Beccati questo oh dov'è questo
telecomando
è caduto l'ho rotto Per sconfiggerlo
dai Forse posso farcela anch'io Aspetta
io un paio di laser anche a te stesso
scarperia Aspetta aspetta
Ah ma lui no aiuto a tirare i laser Ma
com'è possibile cioè attirare il
meteoriti Sì le polpette
Sì ma io non le vedo più
manca poco
allontanati
Cos'è un dinosauro
Beccati questo video
praticamente non si rompe
chi è questo chi sei che sei No Dominick
era un nuovo giocatore agli altri
meteoriti che stanno cadendo dal cielo
concreto
Sì
Escape Room da 1 a 10 gli do uno otto e
mezzo e tu 8
lasciate un bel mi piace Ora vi lasciamo
Qua quattro caselline su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video
che cadono dal cielo la forma Rossa
Buona visione Ciao